misiles rusos caen de nuevo en los
alrededores de kiev y de otras regiones
ucranianas la red eléctrica es el
objetivo esta ofensiva se da luego de
que Moscú acusara kiev de atacar con
drones una flota de la federación rusa
en las costas de sebastopol en la
anexionada Península de crimea
las fuerzas armadas rusas continuaron
sus ataques con armas aéreas y marítimas
de largo alcance y alta precisión contra
El Comando militar y los sistemas de
energía de Ucrania los objetivos de los
ataques fueron alcanzados todos los
objetivos asignados Fueron alcanzados
por su parte el portavoz del presidente
ucraniano bolodimirselenski asegura que
el sistema de defensa antiaéreo logró
interceptar 44 misiles de los más de 50
que Rusia lanzó sin embargo el 80% de
kiev quedó sin suministro de agua
potable algunos residentes se
apresuraron a las tiendas para
abastecerse el agua es por si acaso para
que tengamos un respaldo debido a la
situación nunca y demasiada agua
especialmente en vista del corte de hoy
el suministro de agua se cortó en
nuestra casa por lo que nos hemos
quedado sin agua mientras que al este en
la ciudad de harkif el transporte
público subterráneo se detuvo debido a
los cortes de energía producidos por los
ataques rusos
estoy harto de los rusos pero nadie se
rendirá así como así nos acostumbramos
es el noveno mes de guerra
las autoridades ucranianas dicen que
restablecerán la electricidad en las
zonas afectadas Durante las próximas
horas pero temen por la llegada del
invierno en medio de lo que consideran
una estrategia de Rusia para castigar a
la población civil en medio de la guerra